avec nous ce soir l'entrepreneur et
mécène pierre lassonde qu'on retrouve à
toronto bonsoir monsieur la saône ont
soir au sens désir chez les politiciens
dans les milieux d'affaires de parler de
plus en plus de relancer le plus
rapidement possible l'économie dans les
circonstances monsieur legault a parlé
de lumière au bout du tunnel monsieur
trump aussi d'ailleurs dans un tweet ce
matin un employé les mêmes mots quels
sont vos réflexions là dessus ben
écoutez c'est pas compliqué l'économie
mondiale ne peut pas s'arrêter
complètement que pour une grande période
de temps avant que la les gouvernements
ne soit plus capable de supporter tout
le monde alors il veut de recommencer le
plus tôt possible et mais même avec ça
l'économie va prendre un coup vraiment
dur et ça ne reviendra pas aussi
facilement que ça parce que la partie de
l'économie qui est la plus touchée
c'est la petite et moyenne entreprise
les gens qui ont peut-être cinq à dix
quinze vingt employés et qui n'auraient
qui ont des prêts bancaires qui sont pas
capables de remplir ne t'es pas capable
de lire pays parce qu'ils ont des loyers
impayés et caetera et ensuite l'accord
si vous voulez que j'appellerais des
ouvrières qui s'il veut ne travaillent
pas ils sont capables de mettre du pain
sur la planche alors si on n'est pas
capable on peut leur donner un seul coup
on est capable de leur donner le soutien
mais ça peut pas durer des mois des mots
et des maux alors il faut que ça
recommence
mais moi je crains de mieux vous pensez
que ça va durer combien tu as la crise
dans laquelle nous sommes présentement
de votre point de vue d'investisseur
d'hommes d'affaires vous vous croyez que
ça va durer combien de temps tout cela
on s'en sont en hausse ça ne sera pas
sorti avant au moins 20 22 ah oui et
développer un peu pourquoi vous dites
2022 parce que ça va prendre tout ce
temps là pour réparer le système
si vous voulez bancaire les crédits le
crédit les prêts parce que je regardais
heureusement il se met en tête par dédé
en fait c'est des chiffres qui était
réservé quand j'étais jeune en
astronomie
ils sont tellement énormes ces
chiffres-là d'aider des centaines de
milliards des three lions aux états unis
on parle d'un déficit budgétaire aux
etats-unis 2 25% du produit bleus a
saisi c'est du jamais vu même durant la
guerre mondiale ça jamais été comme ça
alors de penser que ça va avec lille de
la situation à quelques mois non ça ce
ne sera pas comme ça du tout et part en
plus de ça il ya le fait que le prix du
pétrole est tombé dans les 25 dollars
alors vous avez toute l'économie de
l'alberta par exemple du canada qui ne
voient pas nulle part nulle part et on
en saura peut-être par contre mais le
pétrole c'est un très très haut
pourcentage des revenus du gouvernement
fédéral ici au canada
alors tout ça ça va jouer en ce sens que
ma mon avis on en a pour deux ans avant
de se rétablir
oui qu'est ce que ça veut dire donc sur
le prix de l'or vous qui êtes un grand
spécialiste de l'or on a regardé
l'évolution du prix de l'or au cours des
dernières semaines et la valeur refuge
était étonnante à certains moments là le
prix s'est mis à baisser alors qu'on
aurait pensé que c'était un grand refuge
en temps d'incertitudes qu'est ce qui se
passe avec l'or écoutez le fait est ce
que donne au début d'une récession et
sans vous pouvez regarder dans les cinq
dernières récessions le prix de l'or
normalement ne va voir fléchir parce que
étant donné que c'est la valeur refuge
les gens ont besoin de liquidités ils
vont vendre une partie de leurs de leur
or et si ce qui fait que le prix d'abord
peut-être très volatil mais au début
d'une récession on ne performe pas
autant que si vous voulez on pourrait
l'espérer
par contre quand on regarde à tous les
programmes fiscaux qui sont mis en place
par tous les niveaux de gouvernement par
tout le monde entier en europe pendant
le terrain au japon ou aux états unis au
canada
à mon avis il est à peu près certain
qu'on va se retrouver avec de
l'inflation et c'est ce qui fait que
l'or aujourd'hui déjà prévoit
un peu ça en étant déjà dans l'émission
mais 700 dollars aujourd'hui qu'on a vu
à lapointe et moi je prévois des prix
encore plus auxerre dans six à douze bon
combien ben écoutez si je regarde un peu
plus à long terme deux fois dans les
derniers certains le prix de l'or s'est
retrouvé avec un rapport le quand on
regarde au dao jones industrial les
rapports avec l'or en fait c'est une
histoire rapport que j'ai inventé c'est
en 1999 quand ils étaient 42 à 1 c'est à
dire que ça prenait 40 2 onces d'or pour
acheter une unité du dard et bien deux
fois dans les 700 dernières années dont
en 1981 le rapport a été un à un
c'est à dire qu'en 1981 alors été vice
en dollars et le dard étaient 800 à mon
avis dans les cinq prochaines années il
ya des très bonnes chances qu'on revoie
exactement la même chose et je peux le
dire qu'aujourd'hui le dari les 21 22
milles vous allez me dire mais ce que je
sais c'est complètement farfelu convoi
des prix aussi élevés avec les tous les
programmes humanitaires qui ont été
annoncées dans les dernières semaines
pas si farfelue luxueuse du tout du tout
du tout maintenant à ce que le d'havas
est encore 21 22 il faut peut-être
quinze mille peut-être que le rapport
soit pas un ça va être de 1
mais tout ça pour dire que le président
lui même va être beaucoup plus élevé
qu'il est aujourd'hui est ce que le
statut de l'or valeur refuge va changer
avec la crise actuelle et vous changez
un temps et autant que le dollar
américain qui est la devise de réserve
ne n'agit pas comme devise de réserve
quand on dévalue si vous voulez le
dollar américain passe comment alors agi
comme valeur refuge
mais il ya de longs période où
l'économie américaine va bien de ce
qu'ils appellent le gourde il a que dans
les années 80 par exemple lorsque on
avait renault mégane ensuite on a eu
deux autres fontaines pas ce moment là
l'or ne servait pas de vent
revue je pense que le dollar lui même
était une valeur refuge
j'ai toujours dit que l'or c'est l'anti
dollars américains c'est-à-dire que
quand l'odeur là le donneur making fait
bien l'or ne fait pas bien mecha le
dollar américain baisse vis-à-vis toutes
les autres devises
à ce moment là l'or devient valeur
refuge
donc ce n'est pas toujours c'est pas
tout le temps bien monsieur relation
s'arrête ici merci pour votre analyse ce
soir c'est toujours très intéressant ça
fait toujours plaisir
merci merci